talk to me about this tennis player that
just got disappeared in china yeah
so uh feng shui is a there's a very
famous uh
chinese tennis player she's been in
three olympics and a real
superstar
she then put out a message on on social
media
essentially uh or accusing
uh somebody who had actually had been
her her off and on lover for a decade
but who is a a very very senior uh
chinese official
of sexual assault
and then she disappeared
and so there there's been a big
international outcry
more recently there was a call set up
between her and the head of the
international olympic committee which
didn't really
really resolve anything so here's how i
i see that issue um
uh it's a big deal in china for a high
profile celebrity
to make any kind of public claim that's
not aligned with government interest let
alone
to accuse a member of the former member
of the chinese politburo
of a sexual assault
from the chinese government perspective
i think the reason why they move so
aggressively to squash her and her
message
is i think they're afraid of a metoo
movement in china because in china
like in many other countries i can give
you a 100 percent guarantee
that many senior members of the chinese
communist party have assaulted women
over time and abused their power there's
a hundred percent chance of that it's
not just in china it happens in
countries all around all around around
the world if there were
a metoo movement has happened in the
united states in france and in many
other places
the chinese government fears
that
could get out of hand and it's exactly
why with falun gong which is kind of
like a spiritual yoga club and china
attacked them and has imprisoned and
killed many members of of falun gong the
chinese communist party is afraid of any
kind of social organization
not sanctioned by them and they're
afraid of any person
getting the ability to deliver a message
contrary
to the message of the chinese communist
party so that's why jack ma the richest
man in china he criticizes the chinese
government and he vanishes
fon bing bing who's one of the lead
actresses is accused of of not playing
by the rules he disappears and has to
come back
much later groveling and asking for
forgiveness we've seen this story over
and over and over and the theme of it is
the chinese communist party
will do anything
to control its narrative and that's the
connection with the covet origin i mean
they have their story
they'll do whatever it takes
to defend their story and that's why
with with feng shui they're willing to
crack down they don't want to lose the
olympics uh but it's great that there
are people like ines cantor of the
boston celtics who are who are raising
really important questions and and
challenging china and on covet origins
that's why we have to demand a full
investigation just like we have to
demand that china
be
that if they want to host the olympics
if they want
to get this opportunity to be part of
the international community it comes
with obligations and that's why more
broadly
i've called for every media organization
that's covering the olympics to spend 25
percent of their full media time
covering issues of uh tibet xinjiang
south china sea human rights
in china every corporate sponsor uh
that's spending on the the beijing
olympics should spend 10 percent of its
full spend supporting the victims of
these atrocities and whether they're
tibetans uyghurs or investing in in
supporting uh organizations fighting for
democracy in hong kong and many other
situations it is crazy that china can be
a part of a global movement which is the
olympics sport it's the winter olympics
they've got next year right and um
and yet not play by the rules that the
rest of the world
adheres to or says is fair there is
something
yeah there's something icky about the
entire china situation which
i guess is that
we require them to keep the capitalist
machine moving forward
there is also
perverse incentives
people being monetized you saw that
ridiculous turnaround who was that
wrestler that gave the uh oh my god um
john cena john cena it was i actually
tweeted against him i mean it is
let me just use this opportunity to
condemn john cena john cena if you're
listening to this podcast you are a
scoundrel you're supposed to be a tough
guy that's your entire brand and chyna
criticizes you and you get on your hands
and knees and bark like a dog
show some backbone talk to inez cantor
that's what courage looks like standing
up for things standing up for people and
standing up for human rights and i
challenge you john cena to come on this
podcast with me and let's have the
conversation about china if you think
that the chinese communist party is
doing such a great job if they are
supporting human rights so much that
you'll do everything you can to support
them come and and make that case and
let's have a conversation
you heard it john cena uh yeah i mean
it's
man it's so it's it makes me feel so
icky it makes me feel so uncomfortable
generally the the whole situation around
china going back to uh pong shui and the
other people that kind of get
disappeared for a while what do you
think happens
do you think i mean are they being taken
away and tortured are they being taken
away and
what is it that they're not taking away
so the chinese government is very
sophisticated i don't think that feng
shui or jack ma or fon bin bing none of
them were were tortured as a matter of
fact i'm certain of it but the chinese
government has a lot of levers over
people like that they can
destroy their lives
they can imprison their
relatives they can take away their means
of making a living of communicating
with their with their fans so they
really have
a lot of of leverage and they're fully
willing to use that leverage when they
feel it's it's necessary including
against other members of the chinese
communist party
who get on on the wrong side
like uh
well i mean like many of them
and so that's what they're that's what
they're doing and that's frankly why uh
the many scientists who i believe almost
certainly have a lot of relevant
information of the origins of the
pandemic they don't dare speak certainly
they've been threatened by the chinese
government there are laws preventing
them from speaking
but if they speak even if they make a
run for it and and get outside of the
country
and speak their families will be in very
significant
danger so this is this is a very
thorough control mechanism when you saw
the first photos
of feng shui and she was surrounded by
animals people can google this if they
want to try and see i think she posted
it on wechat which is kind of like
chinese facebook and um
it's the most sinister looking room for
somebody that's been missing for a long
time to arrive in is all of these weird
children's toys on a shelf behind her
and then there's a selfie of her holding
one of them it's
the proper horror movie [ __ ]
and so i have no idea whether that's
actually her room or it's a it's a it's
a movie set but regardless let's just
say that that is her room let's we'll
give china the benefit the doubt
some crew from the chinese propaganda
department came there and set up that as
a photo shoot with you and all of your
soft toys you know it's it's it's just
sinister and it's gross and we have to
be honest about it we have to condemn it
and we have to hold china accountable
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you